obrigado o momento todos é um prazer
estar aqui mas sinceramente eu gostava
de pulsar diretamente com ela
perguntando e eu estava com sucesso na
nossa cabeça não existissem indústrias
de defesa
se elas não tivessem feito a diferença o
que o mundo poderia nos ensinar a
maioria das pessoas teria limpo a fazer
serão ministrados de justiça que seja
pra lá e ter mudado a forma como essas
coisas mudaram também ao fim de algum
tempo a forma como todos nós
não se viu nos anos e tecnológicos só
entrando pra nós que lhe concedeu
internet
a internet foi criada durante a guerra
fria época também o censo dos estados
unidos
precisava que em caso do conflito armado
e que nas suas colocações básicas só são
destruídas porque ele assim mãe poderão
ser colocados em qualquer outra
circunstância não tem muitas opções o
texto aumenta sobre elas o então outros
dois envolvidos também presuntos
tributária
esta empresa em 1942 o seu dinheiro é
all star rodas do patinete dos palácios
descobriu com o tablóide popular que
tinha no seu bolso tudo que voa de
tentar identificar o que acontecia os
seus alunos e mais tarde veremos o tento
o chrome os
o ao seu destino é teoria de cimento
vinhos ficar ao seu lado esquerdo
os bbbs os intensos foi tentava leva a
segunda guerra mundial quando é os
departamentos da empresa também oferece
imagens talvez preciso utilizar todos os
seus todos os seus soldados em tento de
batalha hoje em dia a psp utilizado nas
mais diversas plataformas sociais
quero fazer retomar de configurar
inclusive também o equipamento
perfeitamente organizada urubu hoje
pressionados continental gps e como eu
poderia ser desligado em caso de
conflito
outros blocos fizeram obtiveram um
naturalmente desenvolver também o seu
próprio sistema
os russos fizeram isso os chineses
fizeram isso e tenho deus do céu está em
um sistema de gps bola neste momento
estava a correr bem é esse método sim eu
posso final de sua mensagem
obrigado usa hoje em dia é fundamental
do telemóvel foi desenvolvido em 1942 e
patenteado pelo primeiro seus estados
unidos nós orientar que os mísseis eram
lançados por exemplo de fiança porém a
primeira chamada do hotel é o nosso site
para uma futura em 1973 e hoje todos nós
utilizamos
só meus consistentes nas maneiras 10
anos foram descobertos há ainda guerra
civil quando é do senhor nós dos quatros
viu soldados espanhóis decorrerá entre
os quatro carros descolado envolvidas
ainda açúcar porque elas rendimento não
tinham nas mãos
mais tarde quando os estados unidos da
américa a entrar na segunda guerra
mundial foram distribuídos pelos dois
lados implementariam r maneiras aos
fundados porque era um trabalho mais
fácil de transportar e eu ser consumidos
em qualquer contenda com um sentimento
deus clean este sonho quer usar esse
espírito e escrivãos mais desde os entre
ótimas as máquinas fotográficas digitais
aos contadores aos tênis foram
desenvolvidos a partir de modelos
desenvolvidos pela nasa no corpo são
mantidos todos estes desenvolvimentos
foram em que tiveram origem nas
indústrias de defesa e não a do
sentimento da história acrescenta
desenvolvimentos tecnológicos usados que
não tenham partido de alguns ilustres da
indústria de defesa
nós no momento é não ficamos nós ficamos
só preto
cansaço indisposição ou até uma
distração para qualquer pessoa saiu de
dentro de água mas até inclusive eu já
consegui entender alguns salvar vidas
agora na hora daquela comuna na
distância pode fazer um supertempo atual
situação fazer perto do rocha com forte
ondulação do mar
aquilo que adora do mundo já pensarei
pressionando em dois tamanhos muito
jovem dupla sangue de fundo dos
campeonatos pelo apresenta um grande
aumento da toxicidade versã o texto
escrito por max apresentar o equipamento
de controle eletrônico interno integrado
domingo a terceira ter 40 graus
centígrados ia fazer pequenas graus
centígrados
através da circulação do líquido com
três modos de funcionamento automático
baseado no modelo do conforto faixa
seria automático e manual de monte
o campinense-pb comércio que é sobre o
contínuo sincron e 39 no chan2011
inscrição no projovem urbano vai abalar
é discente as proibições ou sair vou
ficar o café se cansou de imóveis felipe
infantil assim como o vento três
segmentos exemplos daquilo que fazem em
portugal nos indústria em maio é horas
foi desenvolvida com o curso ao seu e da
nossa língua portuguesa eo conjunto
nacional no segmento este fato não
prédio é o internacional muito mais que
permitia que o eu sou daslu em tributo
ao sistema possa estar confortável com
cloro pouco frio não vai encontrar um
time é comandado pelas ondas cerebrais
esse nome foi desenvolvido com uma
empresa portuguesa e é procurado na
suécia uma parceria com a fundação
deixando um pequeno exemplo do sal e os
dias 23 de dezembro e 6 2 o peso de 2010
candê 800 nessa construção
este dado no estado que antes isto não
são mais que as empresas vão produzir
produtos seguros dias dos defesa e temos
a certeza de 20 mil pessoas empregadas
no mesmo texto o avião em si nada
naturalmente de ser apoiado
desenvolvidos em touro o outro lado em
sua estréia na quarta formas de certeza
uma ação fundamental o desenvolvimento
destas indústrias os resultados temos
este pequeno exemplo a listar a ideia de
novo nós aos jogos destas indústrias e
eu já nos apoiarmos funcionamento da sua
vida
só estão atuando por cargo ganham os
ingratos para os dentes
o brasil
tudo isto tenha sido furtados clientes
nossas empresas nossa indústria dos
resulta em é tudo alcançar por foi ficou
com a inflação que de resposta estavam
também a subir sustentados jazz funk já
foram do vasco nós e por realizado
conseguimos apanhar essas empresas temos
empresas em portugal que sentia medo
fazendo isso essas empresas com 2 a 1
são o início mas lançadas tem o maior
segmento com grande potencial de
crescimento
e nessa situação é já muitos milhões no
bolso foram sites utilizados por essas
empresas e sim fazer duas defesas não
fizessem força da explosão esta pergunta
é com orgulho que nós dizemos que elas
existem em portugal que têm esta
capacidade
e eu falei vamos apoiar e desenvolver
comprando muito nossa indústria e nossa
economia